since we're on the pro-life issue a
death row inmate named um
john ramirez had his execution halted by
the supreme court on wednesday night
because
he claimed that his religious freedom
was violated if his pastor was not able
to lay hands on him as he was being
executed which apparently is not
something that they allow in texas i
think they allow
i don't know what the rule is exactly
but they allow the pastor in there but
no one is allowed to
make physical contact with the uh with
the condemned as they are being executed
but he said this is a violation of his
religious liberty so the supreme court
came in and they halted it and this is
going to go through the courts again and
then you know um
uh but before the halt was announced
lots of democrats on social media were
once again claiming that pro-lifers are
not really pro-life if they won't stick
up for guys like john ramirez
so here's one example this is a tweet
from a guy named dan green who is he's
he's the national communications
director
for something called democrats for life
these are democrats who actually
consider themselves to be pro-life
and yet they
remain in the democratic party
which is which is
it's like calling yourself a satanist
for jesus it doesn't make any sense at
all
but um this apparently is a group that
exists and probably has about five
people in it here's what he tweeted he
said within a week of an abortion ban in
texas going into effect governor abbott
is killing john ramirez on death row
tonight
the last request of john for his pastor
to hold him as he dies that request was
denied
none of this makes sense we need a
consistent life ethic
uh i agree we need a consistent life
ethic
let me tell you what the consistent
ethic is
and it's actually very simple
it is always wrong
always immoral
and should always be illegal
to directly and intentionally destroy
innocent human life
you need all of those
qualifications
all of those qualifications are
important
uh i mean obviously we can't say it's
always wrong to destroy human life
period because that would mean that you
can't even the self-defense is wrong you
can't shoot if someone breaks in your
house tries to shoot you in the head you
can't defend yourself
that would mean that all all war all war
is bad every single war that's ever been
fought on every side was was wrong
um and that doesn't make any sense
so that's why you need these kind of
qualifications you also
directly and intentionally is an
important part of this too
um
you know every time you get into a
vehicle
there's the chance that you could in
indirectly and unintentionally kill
someone
even
being sober you could still just by
driving down the road
someone could run out in front of your
car and you could kill them
you're driving down the road someone
runs in front of your car you
accidentally kill them are you a
murderer now should you go to jail of
course not
so that's why the pro-life ethic needs
all of those qualifications
they're very important
what about john ramirez
well what did he do to get himself on
death row
he stabbed a convenience store clerk to
death 29 times stabbing 29 times and
killed him
and stole a dollar and 25 cents
so this is a man who who butchered
another man stabbed him 29 times
for less than two dollars
now what i would say to
uh dan green and any other democrat
who advances this talking point but i
say you're pro-life but you
you're in favor of capital punishment
if you can find an unborn baby who's
guilty of stabbing someone 29 times and
killing them
then maybe this comparison will begin to
make sense
but i don't think you're gonna find that
because all unborn babies are
by definition innocent
they've done nothing they haven't harmed
anyone
they are the most innocent human beings
on the planet
they haven't had the opportunity to to
make any bad choices or to intentionally
harm anybody
so
that's the difference
you know this
comparison
like acting like you can't like you
don't see any substantive difference
between a baby
and a murderer who stabbed someone to
death 29 times
i'm not sure i even believe it i'm not
sure that i believe that you don't see
the difference
and this is another example where it
actually works the other way just like
the bodily autonomy argument
you know that works for vaccines it
doesn't work
it actually works against the
pro-abortion side
because what about the bodily autonomy
of the unborn baby who you're destroying
so with this when the the democrats
raise the you know the supposed pro-life
hypocrisy on capital punishment the
hypocrisy goes the other way
they're the ones who have a
contradiction that they need to explain
you know
it doesn't trouble me at all to say
that
i am not in favor of executing babies in
the womb
but i am in favor of executing convicted
murderers that's my position
for a lot of pro-life people not all
that's our position
but for most democrats
uh their position is
the only people that they're in favor of
executing are unborn babies
they're saying don't execute the
criminal but execute the unborn baby
so who
whose position is more inconsistent
which which position needs
uh
needs further justification and
explanation
the position that we should only execute
convicted murderers or the position that
we should only execute unborn babies
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content